[Musique]
mon enfant chéri documentaire exclusif
et réalisé par Nicolas Bourgoin qu'il a
initié avec Mélissa Theuriau qui a
produit ce documentaire ou le témoignage
vous venez de le voir de 5 parents
issus de différents milieux sociaux et
de tout âge mais ayant un point commun
l'un de leurs enfants se consume dans
les drogues sans qu'il sache vraiment
comment pouvoir l'aider sans qu'il sache
vraiment comment espérer mettre un terme
à cette addiction mortifère et c'est
bien sûr de ce problème auquel de
nombreuses familles peuvent être
confrontées dont nous allons débattre
maintenant avec nos invités présents sur
ce plateau de débat doc en commençant
par vos professeurs Amin Benyamina
bienvenue vous êtes psychiatre vous
officiez à Paris Saclay et vous êtes par
ailleurs le président de la Fédération
Française
d'addictologie également avec nous
Grégoire grimpe bienvenue à vous
êtes un ancien toxicoman vous êtes
actuellement en train de monter un
groupe de parole à Angers
auprès de personnes toxicoman par le
biais de l'association les narcotiques
Anonymes Grégoire aujourd'hui 4 ans 91
après être passé par bien des péripéties
avoir vécu un enfer je pense qu'on peut
dire les choses comme ça mais
aujourd'hui vous en êtes sortis vous
nous expliquerez un petit peu ce qui a
été le chemin bien entendu pour en
arriver là où vous en êtes aujourd'hui
puis enfin avec nous Virginie Barcelo
bienvenue à vous
vous êtes une un ancien une mère d'un
enfant toxicomane il s'appelle
Jean-Baptiste vous êtes la mère de deux
enfants et Jean-Baptiste c'était l'aîné
hein de vos deux enfants vous êtes
reconnus dans le témoignage de ses
parents qu'est-ce que vous a paru le
plus fort dans ce film dans dans cette
parole portée par ses parents dont les
enfants dont l'un des enfants est
toxicoman là où on se retrouve c'est le
fait d'être perdu d'être perdu d'être
complètement démuni
et de pas savoir quoi faire quelles
décisions prendre c'est très compliqué
et aussi ce que disait Roseline Fabre
c'est que on arrive des fois les
détester mais en fait l'amour qu'on la
porte fait tout en fait on tient un bon
pour ça on en arrive à détester ces
enfants quelques minutes il y a des fois
on en peut plus mais voilà on est solide
on essaie de tenir bon et d'avancer et
c'est indispensable commençons par le
commencement Jean-Baptiste je crois il
commence à fumer du cannabis à 15 ans
l'entrée c'est souvent le cannabis on en
parlera d'ailleurs c'est cette drogue
cannabis c'est souvent par là qu'entre
les enfants
dans la toxicomanie les premiers signes
que vous avez que vous avez pu percevoir
le premier sentiment que vous avez eu
sur l'attitude qu'il fallait adopter
avec Jean-Baptiste à ce moment là
c'est assez compliqué parce qu'au début
c'est des drogues de l'école donc on se
dit il essaye de faire comme ses copains
on ne pense pas que ça peut devenir
aussi dangereux donc au début ne fume
pas déjà la cigarette ne fume pas des
joints évidemment et puis on se rend
compte qu'il devient un peu rebelle on
se dit c'est la naissance c'est
peut-être normal et ensuite
on ne voit pas tout de suite où on ne
veut pas voir je ne sais pas mais en
tout cas nous on n'a pas vu tout de
suite on s'en est rendu compte quand il
a eu
sept ans que là il prenait des produits
autrement dit deux ans plus tard voilà
qu'on ne connaissait pas enfin on avait
entendu parler mais on ne connaissait
pas vraiment
quel danger vraiment vraiment à quel
point ça pouvait les détruire donc ces
deux premières années est-ce que vous en
avez parlé à votre entourage à vos amis
c'était à vous ah oui absolument
absolument parce qu'on ne sait pas
comment aborder le sujet et puis
beaucoup de personnes personnes disent
bon peut-être peuvent porter des
jugements où vont dire peut-être tu
aurais dû faire ci ou tu aurais dû faire
ça on en a parlé à nos amis très très
proches après c'est pas la faute des
autres personnes c'est simplement qu'on
est fatigué de répéter de parler de
malheur tout le temps de ce qui va pas
voilà donc du coup on se met en retrait
effectivement ça arrive pour toutes les
familles on se met en retrait et on
reste avec un tout petit cercle d'un
livre vraiment sur Grégoire quel âge la
première consommation là aussi de
cannabis je crois cannabis 16 ans et
comme vous venez de le dire c'est vrai
que c'est souvent la porte d'entrée moi
je fais pas mal de témoignages et en
fait souvent quand je dis aux jeunes
comment dire
si vous fumez un joint vous allez pas
forcément finir héroïnommable ou
d'autres trucs beaucoup plus fort mais
tous les gens que j'ai rencontrés que je
connais qui ont pris des drogues bien
plus durs on commençait par un joint
c'est vraiment c'est vrai que c'est la
porte d'entrée mais pour appuyer ce
qu'elle dit c'est le joint qui semble
créatif léger peut en fait être vraiment
mais très pernicieux et en fait peut
devenir une drogue dure en soi vraiment
le joint récréatif la drogue récréatif
on entend souvent ces termes chez les
jeunes parce qu'ils font la fête avec
leurs amis à partir du moment de quel
moment chez vous de quel âge ça n'a plus
été du tout recréatif
pas moi le truc c'est que c'est devenu
assez rapidement au début récréatif mais
très rapidement une addiction qui venait
combler un manque à léger une angoisse
une souffrance donc honnêtement
rapidement à 16 ans j'ai commencé à
fumer les joints et très rapidement j'ai
commencé à consommer seul de mon propre
côté et le fameux rituel de le soir pour
dormir il me fallait un joint au moins
quoi c'est lorsqu'on commence à
consommer seul que que la pente commence
progressivement à faire jour il y a tous
les éléments étaient en TDI j'ai trouvé
le document exceptionnel de par là où la
part lequel il a été fait c'est-à-dire
on est allé voir la problématique de la
drogue en France par les parents et ça
c'est assez raré je voulais vous le dire
c'est plutôt vraiment pour nous pour des
cliniciens un regard intéressant la
souffrance des parents complètement par
la souffrance des parents évidemment on
imagine bien la souffrance des concernés
également par la souffrance des parents
les éléments que Grégoire vient de citer
sont des éléments cliniques que l'on
connaît la précocité de la consommation
c'est à partir duquel on commence à
rentrer dans la consommation des règles
notamment le cannabis et plus l'âge et
précoce c'est-à-dire avant 15 ans ou aux
alentours de 15 ans et plus le risque
est élevé la consommation solitaire
c'est souvent un symptôme d'un isolement
qui peut aussi nous renseigner sur ce
qu'on appelle les vulnérabilités de la
personne et derrière élément et qui est
important ça tout a été dit c'est
l'utilisation de ce produit comme un
élément autothérapeutique c'est-à-dire
auto soulagement je le prends pour
combler quelque chose ou pour gérer
peut-être une angoisse mais tout ça ne
constitue pas des éléments qui vont nous
amener vers quelque chose qui ressemble
à la toxicomanie plus tard et un
changement de produit mais ce sont des
éléments qui doivent d'emblée nous
orienter est-ce qu'on peut distinguer
malgré tout des profils parmi ceux qui
en restent à la drogue créative au joint
du samedi soir et ceux qui qui vont
accentuer leur consommation de drogue
qui plus est vers des drogues de plus en
plus addictifs de type coca
pourquoi pas
MDMA
dropshimique
est-ce qu'on distingue clairement les
profils et et quels sont les profils qui
basculent le plus où se trouve la
fragilité alors on a tendance à dire et
ce qui est vrai la toxicomanie c'est la
rencontre entre un produit une personne
et un environnement et lorsque les trois
éléments sont réunis on a plus de chance
d'aller vers quelque chose de plus
compliqué c'est à dire un environnement
qui offre la drogue pardon dans les
structures de soins en parlera tout à
l'heure quand il y en a pas un appât
c'est comme ça le profil c'est d'abord
des traits de caractère des
personnalités on a affaire à des jeunes
qui sont des chercheurs de sensations
qui n'ont pas perdu danger et qui et qui
aiment bien avoir des expériences
nouvelles ça c'est important et puis on
a des facteurs psychologiques
la timidité ou bien tout le contraire
c'est quelque chose qui est très ouvert
qui évolue Bill donc ça c'est des
éléments il y a la personne et puis il y
a les facteurs sociaux on a bien vu dans
le document on a souvent mais c'est
triste mais c'est la réalité souvent à
faire à des jeunes de parents divorcés
ou bien de niveau socio-conique qui a
été
finalement impacté par la vie des
problèmes économiques ou bien dans des
situations sociales de grands événements
comme des guerres ou bien des problèmes
économiques tout ça constitue des
éléments de vulnérabilité qui peuvent
finalement sélectionner des jeunes qui
seront plus exposés vous est-ce que vous
rentriez dans ce cadre en précisant par
exemple que vous avez perdu votre père à
l'âge de 12 ans vous aviez un terrain de
fragilité car après coup maintenant vous
que vous identifiez mon père a décidé
quand j'avais 14 ans d'un cancer il est
tombé malade quand j'avais 12 ans donc
j'ai vraiment vu la maladie le dégrader
son état et surtout moi j'avais donc
j'avais une espèce de le père absent et
il y a eu une espèce de plus grande
hypersensibilité il faut le dire moi à
12 ans sans être dépendant de quoi que
ce soit j'ai été anorexique donc j'avais
voyez une fragilité psychologique qui en
fait a fait que j'ai été
ultra sensible à 16 ans quand j'ai
commencé Virginie chez Jean-Baptiste il
y avait ce type de fragilité que vous
aviez peut-être identifié ou identifié
après coup on en parlant pourquoi pas
avec un confrère un psychiatre peut-être
après mon mari était dans la Marine
nationale donc
voilà souvent ça aussi
donc aussi peut-être le besoin de de la
reconnaissance en se disant je suis
l'aîné je dois montrer l'exemple
peut-être trop de pression à l'école
c'est difficile de savoir c'est
difficile je pense que lui c'était dans
une drogue festive comme on dit et puis
au moment donné il a une fragilité qu'il
a été obligé de combler c'était devenu
trop et il pouvait plus s'en passer
il n'y a pas de d'un élément isolé
déterminant on peut en même temps avoir
tous ces éléments et ne pas rentrer dans
la toxicomanie quand on va la prévalence
de la consommation du cannabis pour les
citer en France si tout le monde devait
avoir ce parcours on serait dans un pays
qui serait totalement seveli par envahi
en détruit une jeunesse détruite n'est
pas le cas donc c'est
pas de chance en quelque sorte d'une
certaine manière et il faut le dire
d'autant plus que c'est un document qui
parle des parents et les parents portent
tous en eux une forme de culpabilité ils
se disent où j'ai loupé
où j'ai été absent qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé on le sent très fort dans ce
documentaire et dans les témoignages qui
nous sont livrés dans ce film j'imagine
que cette culpabilité voulait accentue
tous les jours de votre vie durant cette
période très précisément il y a un
moment donné on ressent effectivement
cette culpabilité et mais surtout après
on se dit comment derrière ces derrière
comment on va faire maintenant pour être
assez solide surtout pour marcher à côté
de lui dans son choix on va revoir
justement un extrait du documentaire ou
certains et certaines surtout témoignent
de comment justement il y a pas de
structure il y en a pas que ce soit pour
adolescent ou adulte il y en a très peu
c'est de la psychiatrie
alors certes c'est de la psychiatrie
quelque part aussi parce que à force de
consommer il développe des troubles
finalement de la personnalité on est
bien d'accord mais à la base ils sont
pas schizophrène ils sont pas bipolaires
ça ne rentre pas dans ce cadre et donc
il y a pas de structure adaptée donc
pour étayer ce que vous venez de nous
dire à l'instant il n'y a pas de
structure adaptée c'est le constat que
vous avez fait aussi lorsqu'il a fallu
aider du point de d'un point de vue
clinique
votre fils alors quand on se rend compte
rencontres de l'urgence de la situation
qui a s'il y a une prise de trop grosses
prises de médicaments qu'il faut aller à
l'hôpital en urgence et là on découvre
le milieu hospitaliers c'est vrai que
c'est pas évident la psychiatrie c'est
très dure il devrait ils sont obligés
d'y aller mais malheureusement c'est
quelque chose de difficile
à l'époque je ne sais pas comment c'est
maintenant parce que j'ai l'impression
qu'on en parle de plus en plus mais à
l'époque les parents n'étaient pas
concernés par exemple un jour j'ai amené
mon fils chez un psychiatre il était il
était à peine majeur il m'a dit non
madame vous ne rentrez pas j'ai dit je
veux pas entendre ce qui va vous dire
mais je voudrais faire ce chemin avec
lui il vit chez nous on a besoin d'être
prévenu pour l'aider donc il faut qu'on
soit concerné et effectivement une autre
fois on a trouvé un psychiatre qui était
vraiment chouette et qui nous faisait
venir
en famille et ensuite Jean-Baptiste a
fait son moment pour lui tout seul mais
c'est très important parce qu'on fait le
même chemin comme disait mon fils
Nicolas l'année dernière il a témoigné
dans une réunion de parents il a dit
chez nous on a tous fait Saint-Jean
espérance toute la famille a fait son
chemin chacun son chemin mais dans la
même direction Saint-Jean espérance a
été évoqué dans ce documentaire on va en
reparler puisque vous y êtes passé hein
Grégoire mais avant d'en arriver à
saint-jean-d'espérance où on vit une vie
monastique pendant trois ans on en
reparlera tout à l'heure il y a d'autres
phases on consulte des addictologues par
quelle phase êtes-vous passé par quelle
praticien êtes-vous passé pour tenter de
mettre un terme à cette addiction
psychiatre
à la base c'était même pour des
angoisses sans forcément lui parler de
ma consommation très rapidement si ils
en parlent dans des commentaires aussi
bah c'est ce qu'on vient de voir là la
mer qui explique que
l'enfant n'est pas schizophrène enfant
n'est pas bipolaire moi il y avait déjà
une fragilité mais c'est vrai que ça
stimulait réveillé quelque chose donc
qui m'a énormément angoissé enfin qui
m'a fait faire des séjours
psychiatriques donc vraiment psychiatre
au début addictologue c'est venu plus
tard mais c'est vrai que au début mes
problèmes de cannabis m'ont vraiment
amené dans le milieu psychiatrique à
traiter de la dépression un peu de
bipolarité donc des antidépresseurs mais
après ça va être vraiment à l'âge de 23
ans psychiatrique c'est-à-dire plusieurs
jours à l'hôpital ah oui des parents un
mois deux mois après il y a un téléphone
il y a prise de contacter à l'extérieur
mais ça implique oui à se retrouver avec
des patients qui n'ont pas forcément la
même pathologie la même problématique
mais ça va vraiment être vers 22h23 ans
quand je suis tombé notamment dans la
cocaïne où là je me suis retrouvé dans
des services plus de addictologie
voilà psychiatrie côtoyer et là à bruit
addictologue attendez j'ai même un
moment donné j'ai fait une cure après je
suis allé en poste cure la Poste cure
qui est censée être le passage parce que
la cure ça va durer un mois deux mois
mais bon on est encore très fragile donc
post-cure je suis carrément aller dans
les Pyrénées j'ai pas j'étais à 7 mois
d'abstinence oh chut le problème
toujours c'est le après des cures de
quelle durée en moyenne ah bah là
c'était 3 mois 3 mois les parents n'ont
pas trouvé de de structures adaptée dans
ce documentaire Virginie a eu les pires
difficultés à le faire aussi je
comprends tout à fait et là là c'est
quoi inquiéter ceux qui nous regarde
quand même c'est pour ça que c'est très
bien de passer chez vous la dictologie
est une discipline jeune c'est le
croisement de plusieurs savoirs dont la
psychiatrie mais ce n'est pas que de la
psychiatrie et la plupart des parents
jusqu'à présent
un peu moins maintenant quand il y a le
symptôme patent le symptôme que l'on
voit c'est de l'angoisse c'est de
l'agitation c'est du mal-être c'est des
idées suicidaires forcément on va voir
le psychiatre en revanche ce qu'on a en
vérité c'est la gestion de deux éléments
la psychiatrie les symptômes
psychologiques psychiatriques et les
problématiques addictives les
psychiatres qui n'ont pas de formation
dans les addictions c'est de moins en
moins le cas ne prennent en charge que
la souffrance on essaye d'une manière un
peu empirique de prendre en charge la
problématique addictive en revanche de
plus en plus la dictologie c'est une
discipline qui mène dans cette organisée
produit des psychiatres mais pas que
mais qui ont une capacité à gérer les
deux en même temps c'est l'enjeu complet
et des structures comme cela il y en a
pas beaucoup c'est pour ça que là c'est
le président de la Fédération Française
d'addictologie qui s'exprime on essaye
d'avoir ce type de structure pour voir
d'abord accueillir ces patients
complexes pour gérer les deux accures
les parents mettre en place des
structures adaptées travailler avec les
patients travailler avec les
associations les envoyer dans
constructeur de posture comme à Val
Pyrène
c'est très bien et donc c'est tout ça
c'est tout ça qui permet d'abord de
gérer la l'urgence c'est le sevrage et
les problématiques psychiatriques pas
tant et surtout ce qui fait que l'on
sort c'est gérer l'abstinence et la
gestion de la rechute c'est ça qui est
important et c'est tout ça qui demande
du savoir du savoir-faire et des moyens
il existe des centres en France pour les
toxicomanes les Carus de les centres
d'accueil et d'accompagnement à la
réduction des risques pour usager de
drogue 141 structures en France dont 11
à Paris et puis les sapins centre de
soins d'accompagnement et de prévention
à la dictologie
388 établissements en France dont 27 à
Paris vous n'aviez jamais entendu parler
ces fameux centre je voulais préciser
quelque chose au début quand nous nous
avons commencé à chercher on a été à
lavastophar côté de chez nous personne
nous a dit ça il y a ça qui existe qui
existe on nous a dit non renseignez-vous
sur un fodrogue bon un photographe et
c'est juste après Saint-Jean espérance
qu'on a commencé à avoir des adresses
maintenant j'ai effectivement j'ai un
beau carnet d'adresses
que vous avez été fourni par les
thérapeutes par les associations on
cherche de parents de bouche-à-oreille
d'association d'association
très bien j'ai parlé tout à l'heure
après que vous avez parlé d'un fodrogue
c'est vrai qu'une fois j'étais vraiment
mais il m'a orienté un addictologue
quand j'habitais à Paris encore mais là
il y a plein de sang je le mets le
discours que là moi j'ai pas mais c'est
vrai j'ai fait des cures des milieux par
des médecins qui m'ont parlé de
valpyrène j'ai essayé mais rapidement
moi ce qui m'a déstabilisé et que j'ai
rencontré même en milieu psychiatrique
c'est qu'il y a il y a du produit dans
qui circule ce que je comprends c'est
qu'on peut pas mettre des policiers on
va pas faire des fouilles vous voyez non
mais le problème il sait qu'il y a le
même des dealers qui sont dans ces trucs
et donc ça devient très compliqué il y a
toujours le malheureusement le petit con
qui ramène un linge
un jour bien sûr
500 centres en France dont un certain
nombre à Paris ils ont pas l'air connu
c'est centre
où est le problème
ils sont très efficace évidemment les
que ça passe ce sont des structures
ambulatoire
ce sont des structures de basseuil qui
prennent en charge des personnes qui
sont totalement même presque désinséré
on leur donne des soins avec l'accueil
médico-social et que ça passait par elle
mais il y a beaucoup de soins et ensuite
vous savez ce que le niveau 3 c'est les
structures comme la mienne dans laquelle
vous avez une hospitalisation une
consultation adossée un service
universitaire de recherche et
d'orientation donc tout ça ça existe
mais un peu suffisamment il y en a pas
assez il y a pas assez de personnel
formée mais ça c'est en train de se
mettre en place il y a maintenant des
structures il y a des sites pour
lesquels vous pouvez avoir carrément un
jour localisation des structures le site
que j'ai l'occasion enfants que nous
avons créé qui s'appelle addicted.fr
vous allez dessus et vous avez à côté de
chez vous on vous géolocalise à la fois
les collègues qui sont installés en
ville les équipes les associations avec
sapins et vous pouvez sortir en quelque
sorte de des murs dans lesquels jusqu'à
présent en été vraiment il y a des
choses qui ont été mises en France
suffisamment c'est vrai qu'il y en a
quand même pas mal des associations donc
si elles sont intéressantes c'est pas
très enrichissant notamment narcotique
anonymes qui à la base alcoolique
anonymes qui vient de Minnesota aux
États-Unis salade très longtemps ils ont
vraiment développé un programme de
rétablissement qui est très riche en
lui-même parce qu'en fait c'est des
dépendants qui aident des dépendants et
ça c'est très fort et là je suis en
train de monter un groupe des paires
aidants absolument et voilà c'est la
pergence beaucoup beaucoup évolué ces
dernières années dans le cadre des
élections la séparation avec les parents
incontournables pour la réussite d'une
thérapie pas forcément cette mais en
revanche je comprends dans le document
on a vu le témoignage de parents qui
expliquait c'est une manière de faire
ça n'est pas la seule qui peut se
respecter et qui peut donner des
résultats tout est bon vous savez que
moi je pars du principe qu'il n'y a pas
de religion pour sortir une famille ou
une personne de la toxicomanie tout ce
qui marche et qui ne laisse pas dans son
intégrité psychologique et physique la
personne j'ai souscris dans mon service
toutes les obédiences sont sont
autorisées tout le monde s'exprime de la
psychanalyse aux thérapie cognitives
comportementales en passant par les
patients experts qui sont dans mon
service donc là là dessus il y a aucun
problème Virginie vous les avez connu
c'est ces périodes avec votre fils ou
vous n'aviez plus le droit de le voir
ça doit être extrêmement difficile à
vivre cela aussi non il sait même
éloigné de de vous un moment pour aller
chez votre sœur un capital 800 km de
votre domicile ça n'a pas marché ça n'a
pas marché non c'était un pire même on
va dire quand il est parti à saint-jou
espérance déjà on a dit ouf il va être
en sécurité déjà surtout ça en sécurité
et conflit tout ça ça va se poser un peu
parce que sinon c'est ingérable mais
après c'est vrai quand on se dit un an
bon après on pense je pense qu'on est
prêt à tout pour les aider alors à part
les nous de Saint Jean espérance parce
que il en est question dans ce film
votre fils y est passé vous aussi
Grégoire de quoi s'agit-il exactement
c'est une association qui existe depuis
30 35 ans à peu près
à l'époque il y avait quatre maisons en
France jusqu'à il y a peu de temps je
pense que la maison Saint-Joseph a fermé
il y a 5 ans à peu près il y avait deux
maisons mères de garçons et deux maisons
annexes c'est à dire il passe une
première partie du processus du cursus
plutôt un an et demi en maison mère donc
il y a des frères qui s'occupent d'eux
et des laïcs voilà et ensuite quand ils
ont fait cette période ils passent dans
une maison annexe c'est un peu le sas de
sortie ils vivent avec les mêmes
principes que dans la maison où il y a
les frères mais il commence à travailler
et voilà c'est Jean-Baptiste qui a passé
au total trois ans vous aussi Grégoire
trois ans une vie monastique
racontez-nous ce qu'est la vie à
Saint-Jean d'espérance une journée
classique monastique peut-être pas mais
c'est vrai que c'est moi j'ai passé 22
mois en maison mère comme elle
l'expliquait c'est levé 6h et demi on
fait un petit chapelet après on le fait
le ménage on se rasa blanc le petit déj
diclope moi j'ai arrêté j'ai arrêté de
fumer des clopes là-bas aussi mais
autoriser à 10 clopes max pour qu'il
limite après il y a un temps
d'enseignement autant de théologie que
psychologie d'addiction notamment on
voit un peu le les parcours de
narcotiques Anonymes les étapes après
ces chantiers ça c'est un des petits en
gros les piliers de Saint-Jean espérance
c'est la vie communautaire le fait de
vivre avec des frères qui ont une
influence très positive déjà qui ont
aussi la même problématique de la
toxicomanie le travail et donc là ça va
être différents chantiers comme la ferme
mouton cochon de poulet la cuisine le
potager le jardinage un peu de
maçonnerie donc un travail assez manuel
dans le principe de retour réel quoi de
des groupes de paroles on mange le temps
ayant une vie familiale en fait une vie
familiale donc là c'est un espèce de
d'ancien orphelinat donc a vraiment un
cadre idyllique et où on peut se
reconnecter vraiment au présent à
soi-même et essayer le la phrase
d'accroche enfin c'est vivre heureux
sans drogue au bout de combien de temps
vous allez le sentiment que les choses
changeaient chez vous alors les 22 mois
par rapport à votre rapport à la drogue
mon rapport bah moi deux mois deux trois
mois vous sentiez déjà que moi je vous
avoue dès 22 ans 23 ans quand je suis
tombé dans la cocaïne je savais que je
voyais grave et que je voulais m'en
sortir normalement
sur les vins de mois au bout de pendant
franchement pendant 5-6 mois j'avais
envie de crever je voulais sortir faire
une dose fatale et crever mais au bout
de du suicide pardon exactement mais au
bout parce vraiment j'ai dit j'étais un
peu en mode robot je faisais ce qu'on
disait de faire j'ai tenu le coup et au
bout de aller 8 9 mois j'ai sorti la
tête de l'eau aussi par médicament
psychologue la vie est vraiment en gros
c'est un mode de vie très simple et j'ai
commencé à sortir la tête de l'eau et
une vie saine dans un corps sain du
monastique ça fait partie des solutions
visiblement
nos invités présents sur ce plan oui
mais je disais si je pouvais garder mes
passions à 22 mois ben je pourrais
évidemment ça fait rêver vous avez un
dans deux que Grégoire a dit qu'il
recevait du soin mes médicamentseux et
du soin psychologique ce n'est pas un
lieu isolé avec avec des paires en
soutane qui donne une soupe et du du
coton de pain c'est que très élaboré on
est bien d'accord il y a de l'assurance
il y a du savoir il y a de la technique
adosser à une vie communautaire c'est ça
qui est important et ça évidemment on
peut pas le faire partout et on peut
parce qu'une recherche spirituelle à
quelque chose à voir avec ça puisque là
évidemment ce sont c'est une association
laïque mais sont des moines qui
personnellement
pour ma part je répète on peut trouver
la même chose avec des associations ou
bien des mouvements laïques ou bien
spirituel autre que religieux on va pas
leur tomber dessus c'est pas le but
c'est pas ça parce qu'ils font des
choses de grande qualité je sais pour
avoir vu des jeunes sorties de là il
faut un travail en plus ils sont ils
sont ils sont transparents ça se passe
pas trop mal et je pense que là dessus
ce qu'il faut avoir en tête c'est que il
faut y avoir une il faut avoir une
philosophie et que les gens quand ils
viennent voir ces structures savent ou
mettre leurs enfants et savent ce qui
s'y fait c'est le cas un autre extrait
du documentaire parce qu'il est souvent
question malgré ses thérapie que nous
avons évoqué ensemble par laquelle vous
êtes passé un Grégoire il peut y avoir
des rechutes
il est dans une clinique dans le sud le
mot clinique n'est pas peut-être le bon
mot un centre on va dire où ils ont une
certaine liberté c'est à dire que ils
sont encadrés
les infirmiers des médecins mais ils
sont en
totale liberté dans le sens où ils
peuvent sortir ils sont pas enfermés et
si vous faites une connerie si il
consomme il est viré
pour l'instant il s'accroche donc
parce que ce qui pose problème en fait
c'est la sortie c'est sortir de ces
retrouver la vie affronter la vie en
fait c'est ça le problème
et oui ce qui pose problème c'est la
sortie dit-elle concerne de France 24
d'ailleurs qui témoigne dans ce dans ce
film alors ce témoignage est intéressant
parce que on voit qu'on a à faire des
profils parfois différents parfois la
drogue est plus importante que la
maladie mentale ou bien la
décompensation mentale et parfois c'est
le contraire et donc on a plus besoin de
médicaliser d'organiser le soin sur le
plan psy et gérer la problématique
toxicomaniaque et ça dépend des périodes
de la vie c'est peut-être qu'en ce
moment
c'est le cas du fils de votre collègue
et peut-être c'est moi le cas de
Grégoire un moment et on peut avoir ces
cycles ces cycles qui vont et qui
viennent et qui font qui fait que on a
besoin d'aller pas dans une structure
mais dans certains structures en
fonction du type de décompensation dans
lequel on se trouve comme je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure c'est la coexistence
entre la souffrance psychologique et la
consommation des drogues qui fait qu'on
choisit en fonction du moment la
meilleure structure Grégoire on l'a dit
un 4 en abstinence rechute de temps en
temps ou pas sur les quatre ans
d'abstinence non l'abstinence
ah oui oui moi ça a été un parcours de
de de de conso d'arrêt de rechutes ah
oui ça a été un parcours du combattant
vraiment mais honnêtement dans ce qu'il
expliquait moi ce qui a un moment donné
a fait avec ce que ça a pu déclencher
chez moi comme pathologie fragilité on
pourrait même parler de psychose on fait
que Saint-Jean était le bon endroit et
il me fallait un endroit où il y a zéro
possibilité
ce qu'il faut avoir en tête c'est quand
on a décompensé une pathologie
psychiatrique quel que soit la nature
dépression anxiété trou bipolaire tout
la consommation des produits vient
réactualiser les problématiques aussi et
parfois les problématiques psy en légère
en reconstromant les drogues lorsqu'on
n'est pas encadré et donc on est dans un
cercle infernal et vicieux et on sait
pas qui est c'est l'histoire de l'oeuf
et de la poule on ne sait pas mais on
sait pas qui est à l'origine de du
démarrage c'est la raison pour laquelle
la prise en charge elle est elle est
concomitante la prise en charge de cette
pathologie elle est à la fois sur la
gestion des crédits comme maladie sur la
gestion des produits et sur la
problématique psychiatrique qu'il faut
gérer par des médicaments par des
psychothérapies le génie excuse
Jean-Baptiste a rechuté après son
passage à saint-jean-d'espérance ou
est-ce que c'est bien l'abstinence
aujourd'hui qui fait partie de la vie de
votre fils il a rechuté il a eu une
rechute
un peu plus long que les autres c'est à
dire de semaine donc c'est pas énorme et
puis les deux ou trois autres fois
c'était des cravings c'est-à-dire une
pulsion irrépressible de consommer le
cerveau se Briche par si c'est les bons
termes se met sur OFF il a plus moyen de
dire non je ne veux plus c'est comme ça
il faut y aller et là il consomme il va
voir une bouteille de vodka ou ce qu'il
a sous la main pas il a pu consommer de
drogue depuis trois ans en tout cas
est-ce que vous avez retrouvé le
Jean-Baptiste que vous ayez connu
adolescent mieux encore beaucoup mieux
oui les plats de vie il est super
sportif
non non et puis quand il a un crédit ça
dure deux jours et puis c'est fini il
reprend son boulot il y a tout qui se
remet en place il y a des choses très
positives il arrive il commence à
comprendre à comprendre les petits
signes à gérer différemment à accepter
les mains tendues aussi c'est pas
évident de nous prévenir quand ça va pas
donc il y a beaucoup de choses positives
c'est un travail qu'on fait et c'est
bien
il a trouvé une compagne il a une petite
compagne et ça c'est terminé mais voilà
il vient d'une bonne vie il fait de la
musique est très sportive donc il
travaille il est content pour l'instant
tout va bien ben voilà une autre positif
les parents le disent très bien
lorsqu'ils découvrent la toxicomanie
leurs enfants c'est que c'est vraiment
un effondrement ils font le deuil de
l'enfant réel l'enfant idéal pour ça
fait longtemps les enfants on veut tout
ce que nos enfants soient politiques
peu importe et un moment donné la
confrontation avec la réalité c'est la
toxicomanie et bien ensuite on fait le
deuil et on construit on a ce que vous
venez de dire quelqu'un qui est mieux
passe non c'est pas qu'il est pas mieux
vous avez quelqu'un qui est réel qui a
appris à vivre qui s'est construit qui
fonctionnait au sens le plus social du
terme moi je dis souvent aux parents
attention
le rétablissement en matière
psychiatrique et addictologique
il est très subtil par exemple quand on
sera sur une jambe on peut boiter un peu
mais on va travailler on peut faire du
sport c'est pareil pour les problèmes de
psychiatrie toxicomanie n'attendez pas
d'eux qu'ils soient parfait attendez
qu'il soit capable de gérer leur vie
d'avoir du travail et d'avoir une
campagne ou un compagnon Grégoire vous
étiez le dernier d'une fratrie de 6
ouais est-ce que le fait de d'être
abstinent aujourd'hui à relier renouer
avec la vie sociale renouer avec avec
vos frères vos sœurs est-ce que vous
allez retrouver une vie sociale que vous
aviez totalement perdu durant la période
très sombre de votre existence en grande
partie oui clairement notamment
l'histoire avec les parents c'est déjà
qu'il y a plus de mensonges en fait et
notamment ma mère me fait me refait
confiance c'est incroyable elle en vient
même à me dire oui est-ce que tu as
besoin d'un peu d'argent quand elle m'a
dit ça il y a six mois j'ai j'ai fait
waouh elle me refait quoi elle veut bien
alors je lui ai volé enfin donc ça c'est
incroyable avec une famille ils sont
tous fiers de moi donc c'est très
agréable et je renoue surtout avec le
Grégoire là c'est même pas les proches
c'est moi je Renaud avec le Grégoire que
j'étais le Grégoire qui est sociable qui
a des amis qui voient des gens parce que
moi à un moment donné quand j'étais dans
le fond de la merde c'était vraiment
tout seul mon produit moi et je m'auto
des trucs complètement et la famille à
côté non ça sera le mot de la fin en
rappelant tout de même que nous sommes
les premiers consommateurs en Europe de
au cannabis et que une drogue beaucoup
plus addictive a complètement explosé en
France il s'agit de la cocaïne
consommation multipliée par 4 en
l'espace de 20 ans avec un coup de cette
drogue qui a considérablement baissé ce
qui explique en grande partie que ça
consommation elle est exposée auprès des
jeunes dont on parlait aujourd'hui avec
la loi la plus répressive en Europe
et c'est vrai que nous sommes les plus
répressifs sur ce sujet en Europe merci
vraiment à tous les trois à tous les
deux tout particulièrement pour votre ce
témoignage vous voulez rajouter quelque
chose j'ai très peu de temps vraiment je
voulais saluer le travail de professeur
Benyamine de d'intégrer les parents dans
ce travail avec le jeûne c'est tout vos
réactions ça sera sur hashtag des
bagdock sur Twitter bien entendu merci à
Selma Sally qui m'a aidé comme à la
coutumée à préparer cette émission puis
moi je vous donne tout simplement
rendez-vous pour un prochain débat doc
avec bien sûr sans documentaire et son
débat à bientôt
[Musique]